معنا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك العميد
الياس كيف يمكن قراءه ما يجري في بيل جرود
ضربات تتوسع على مناطق داخل روسيا واخرى
خاضعه لسيطرتها
وسيله هي
لانها فعلا كانت سابقا واليوم هي نقطه
استراتيجيه نقطه لوجستيه مهمه جدا منذ
بدايات الحرب وحتى الان هي المنطقه الاكثر
قربا جغرافيا للتاثير على الساحه الروسيه
من الداخل هذا الامر يعني يترابط مع
الهجوم على
المسيرات الهجوم على موسكو وبالتالي
كرسدونالدونار ايضا فاذا هناك عمليه نقل
ارض المعركه الى داخل الروسي وبوسائل
اوكرانيه بالطبع وهذا الهدف هو فعلا يعني
اضعاف سوره الرئيس
اسقاط المنظومه الامنيه الروسيه كل هذا قد
يكون هدف تكتيكي لخدمه هدف استراتيجي على
وهو يعني التحضير للهجوم المستقبل
الاوكرانيه كيف قرات تصريحات زيلينسكي
الاخيره عن تحدث عن الجبهات النشطه الخطوط
الاماميه
هي جلال هي احدى الرسائل الاساسيه ولكن
هناك تلميحات مستمره عن الهجوم على ان
هناك جوزيه اساسيه على ان الجيش الاوكراني
اصبح جاهزا على انه اوكرانيا تحضر او ما
يسمى
تحضير المسرح للمعركه القادمه
هذه الرسائل مهمه جدا دائما بالاضافه الى
ما يحصل
هي عمليه خداع اساسيه يعني اليوم نرى
عمليه خداع عسكري التركيز في مكان والذهاب
الى مكان اخر هذا الامر شهدناه عندما تم
التركيز على خرسان
واسقى واسقطت خركاف وبالتالي عاد الى
الانسحاب الجيش الروسي منها قصرا وسبب
يعني الحصار اللوجستي كلها امور اساسيه
يعني بين الخطاب بين التحضير بين القصف
بين التحضير المسرح العربي كلها يجب ان
تصب في مكان ما الا وهو التحضير للهجوم
ماذا عن قراءتك لتصريحات
بوتين التي تحدث فيها عن محاولات زعزعه
الاستقرار في روسيا وانه لن يسمح للاعداء
بالقيام بذلك
كما قلت وسيله في بدايه الحديث هذه الامور
ان يكون هناك
ضربات داخل روسيه في اهم مركز ثقل اساسي
نتحدث عن
وكلمه الكريم وسيله تعني الكراميل يعني
القلعه المحصنه منذ ايام المغول
بالقرن الخامس عشر وسادس عشر فاذا هذا
الامر يضرب سوره الرئيس بوتين وهو الذي
وعد الروس ان الحرب هي عمليه خاصه عسكريه
داخل اوكرانيا ها هي الحرب تنتقل الى
الداخل الروسي وهذا الامر يسبب ارباكا
مهمه جدا خاصه في ظل عدم القدره على تحقيق
انتصارات اساسيه لان الجيش الروسي اليوم
ياخذ مواقع دفاعيه بامتياز
شكرا لك العميد الياس حناء الخبير العسكري
واستراتيجي في بيروت